the format is amazing makes you play
hard it makes you I want to compete
against one another each quarter you
have the opportunity to win and it makes
it way more competitive just but one
2400 number two that's a big honor and
you know I wouldn't want in any
different way
representing Kobe in choosing the
tomorrow's knife game
[Music]
I'm just I do my job I'm just trying to
play hard every day tried to stay humble
I'll do whatever it takes to win and you
know I hope the national players can see
that and follow you know my lead step
and the way I follow other guys before
me you know Paul Pau Gasol Manu Ginobili
Tony Parker Toni Kukoc over all of those
guys guy that I gotta mentor me in the
last few years of my career a guy that
you know he was always there for me
in the regular season in the playoffs a
guy that you know told me that whenever
I need something to just reach out to
him and he was really always there if I
needed something takes me back call me
no growing up he was my idol
not just miles probably the whole
generation a lot of people my age I'll
and no for us it was it was the market
children of our generation it was one of
those guys that you know gave back to
the game so much gave back to the
players a lot of people when there is so
great they don't do that you know and
there was a quote that they say that
talent is worthless if you're not
willing to share it right and he was one
of those guys that was selling his
talent with us and he's got me
definitely missed
[Music]
yeah and there's gonna be a long season
obviously is the all-star game you wanna
have fun but at the end of the day you
play against guys that you might meet in
a playoff so you're gonna try to have
fun but this
I'm just competitive you know and I'm
just gonna try to go out there get a win
kill my first all-star once again win
I'm three over three so far but I do
that I just keep a smile on my face
because we got a you know got to put on
a show for the people thank you so much
exactly means having a I'm a little
seasoned he's helping him in any way he
can
obviously they write that thing that
nine eight nine Chicago in a standing so
if it keeps doing this thing they're
gonna be able to make the playoffs and
they gonna be fine
[Music]
who said that the owners said that him
play basketball we do you know our job
is to not take it day by day obviously
we want to meet as many games as
possible but you know our goal is to win
the whole thing so you know obviously as
I said you we want to win every game if
we could win every game that'd be great
but we can't focus we cannot lose track
of our oxygen goal which is get better
every day keep learning every day
and love it
so far haven't had you know time to
enjoy it as much I just I came last
night
I woke up early this morning right now I
think so far my nose my one of my
favorite part was when I was signing
usually when you walk inside some balls
and they kinda hit me that this will be
my fourth year in the all-star game so
you know it's been it's been a long
journey and hopefully we can keep going
so you know now that I have a baby I
kind of feel sleepy and yeah I need some
rest I need sleep but you know obviously
you're in a good place
you know when you have a baby's there
you know Betsy that can never happen to
you is the biggest blessing like you
know bringing a life into this world I
mean a good I'm in a good place I'm
happy so usually when I'm happy I play
go
that also off the court I'll say that
I'm I'm a couch potato of the court
that's one of my best skills and I just
tried to I just try to chill and you
know watch as much TV as I can so
probably one of my skill of the coat is
that I'm a couch potato
I don't know thank you thank you
oh man that's that's far away from now
I'm just trying to you know take it day
by day just try to be in the moment
that's what I've done oh my my whole
career when that opportunity present
itself and I'm able to represent you
know my country and with my brother be
that'd be us and my brothers are also
there but I'm just gonna try to listen
to my body and it you know I'm good
I'm healthy and they give me the
opportunity represent my my country with
my brothers that'd be that'd be awesome
if we can qualify to the Olympics